[Music]
on this thursday night defending the
north
the nato chief's historic trip to
canada's arctic
it's increasingly important that we be
able to defend the region
what it proves to russia distressed and
depressed they often do not get a lunch
break they don't get a coffee break they
have to stay late the deteriorating
mental health of canada's doctors and
nurses deals delays and demand what's
waiting in the wings for air travel this
fall
plus flipping the script for indigenous
peoples there's something out there i'm
coming with you the hollywood
blockbuster made in alberta rewriting
representation
[Applause]
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight bara nasser
good evening and thank you for joining
us a historic and potentially impactful
visit unfolded in canada's north today
for the first time since its inception
the head of nato touched down in the
canadian arctic for a two-day visit and
there's lots to discuss for decades
canada has resisted nato's involvement
in the north but with climate change
heating up security threats and russia
looming on the other side the visit
signals ottawa is warming up to the idea
of help defending a region seen as a
first line of defense for north america
eric sorenson has tonight's top story
it was a photo op only but with a clear
message to russia and the world ottawa
is prepared to work with nato in the
canadian arctic for the first time this
is a
joint canadian u.s facility
this country has long partnered with the
u.s to protect canadian sovereignty the
visit by yen stoltenberg is something
new canada can
show solidarity with nato this is
obviously meant to to be a message to be
sent to putin to demonstrate that
acceptability ottawa recently announced
it was shifting billions of dollars to
modernize continental defense including
new radar systems but critics say the
government has been slow to procure
what's needed we have not under
governments of either national party
shown signs of seriousness about defense
and i'm sure stolenberg has noticed it
seems arctic security has come full
circle 60 years ago the u.s military
built the dewline radar defense system
across canada's north amid the cold war
with the soviet union the north polar
regions offer the most direct quickest
routes for an attack on north american
soil from a wide sector of europe and
asia for a few years the icy relations
thawed but
the war on ukraine has renewed a sense
of urgency russia's hypersonic weapons
suggest canada must upgrade its
capabilities it really
puts a focus on the canadian arctic and
the fact that
our systems up there
are somewhat very limited
the military regularly undertakes arctic
operations nato's secretary general is
taking in the current exercises in the
far north as circumpolar nations worry
about russia's intentions beyond ukraine
particularly as a member of the northern
tier of nato that we do have a a a
responsibility
to be able to respond to the russians
canada remains far short of nato's
expectation that 2 percent of gdp go to
defense spending
but ottawa appears to recognize the
arctic is a priority where it must spend
more
eric sorensen global news toronto
for the first time in history ukraine's
apparition nuclear power plant occupied
by russian forces was temporarily cut
off from the power grid
these satellite photos show nearby fires
that damage the plant's transmission
lines forcing the disconnection the
nuclear plant is europe's largest
ukrainian staff are still operating the
plant but the site's been controlled by
russian forces since the early days of
its invasion of ukraine
the death toll from a russian rocket
attack on a train station in a small
eastern ukrainian town has risen
officials now say at least 25 people
were killed dozens more injured as the
country marked its 31st independence day
russia meanwhile claims it killed 200
ukrainian soldiers in the attack
a soviet era monument came down with a
splash in latvia's capital today the
80-meter monument made up of five spires
and topped by soviet stars commemorated
the red army's victory over nazi germany
it's the latest soviet monument to be
taken down since russia's invasion of
ukraine it was built in 1985 when latvia
was still part of the soviet union
tonight we're getting a clearer picture
of how canadian doctors and nurses are
coping with an under-resourced health
care system with overcrowded hospitals
and ongoing staffing shortages a new
surveys painting a grim picture of their
mental well-being overwhelmed overworked
and trying to manage another surge in
patients after what's already been a
trying few years has left them burnt out
beyond their limit
karen lieberman reports on the effects
on their health
it's hard to
tell you
just what it's like to see the ravages
of covet 19. dr laura harry luck
remembers the exact moment in the
pandemic when she realized she was not
okay and it had nothing to do with her
role in the intensive care unit i got a
request from a friend internationally
and it was to develop or revamp
some educational
modules that we use and i just remember
feeling overcome by anxiety
and panic
as cases of covid19 decline canadians
may be feeling a sense of normalcy but
on the front lines every person has
their their limits and when those limits
are repeatedly and continually stressed
it'll wear down even the most resilient
among us and that's really the situation
that candidates physicians find
themselves in a survey conducted by the
canadian medical association beginning
in october shows more than half of
respondents reported experiencing
symptoms of burnout 1.7 times higher
than four years ago
while the focus is on physicians the
crisis extends to other health care
workers including nurses they often do
not get a lunch break they don't get a
coffee break they have to stay late they
have to do doubles half of the surveys
respondents say they're dissatisfied
with their work life integration meaning
they don't feel they're meeting personal
and professional obligations
an overwhelming number say they aren't
professionally fulfilled
yet physicians work more hours in an
average week than any other canadian
employee with medical residents spending
the most time on patient care when there
are staffing shortages it inevitably
means that
the clinicians who are there have to
work
longer hours
family doctors and primary care clinics
in bc are getting a 118 million dollar
boost from the province and doctors of
bc but countrywide physicians are
calling for longer-term solutions
i
couldn't keep up with it dr darren
marklin recently gave up one of his two
specialties a lack of support he says
continues to cause him stress i look at
our alberta healthcare board and there's
no physicians on it we have lawyers and
business people that tells me what
direction you're going in i'm terrified
like i know they don't have my back
karen lieberman global news toronto
toronto public health has declared an
outbreak of meningococcal disease in the
city with one person who died
the agency sounded the alarm after
confirming three people including the
person who died fell ill with the
disease in july all were born in
countries that did not provide childhood
immunizations against it adults aged
between 20 and 36 are now urged to get
vaccinated if they haven't been
meningococcal disease is caused by
bacteria it's spread through contact
with respiratory and throat secretions
and it can cause dangerous infections of
the brain spinal cord and bloodstream
there's some hopeful news though tonight
about another concerning outbreak the
number of monkey pox cases reported
globally dropped more than 20 percent in
the last week and as dan spector reports
it may be a signal public awareness and
vaccine campaigns are working and just a
quick warning this story contains some
graphic images
for months montreal was the epicenter of
the monkey pox outbreak in canada at his
clinic dr rejean tomah was seeing a
constant stream of new patients dealing
with painful lesions caused by the virus
but recently he says things have changed
since august
we have an important decrease
of the of the case at the same time dr
tama is noticing less monkey pox on the
front lines the world health
organization says the number of new
cases around the globe is dropping last
week the number of weekly reported cases
fell by more than 20 percent globally
the news is not all good the who says
though the situation is improving in
europe north and south america are
seeing increases in latin america in
particular
insufficient awareness or public health
measures
are combining with a lack of access to
vaccines
to fund the flames of the outbreak
the united states has the most cases of
any country with more than 16 thousand
here in canada there are now just over
1200 cases ontario has the most with 583
and quebec has 471 not the time to drop
our guard says dr tama now we have to
understand i think it's too early the
virus is spread through prolonged
physical contact and is mostly affecting
men who have sex with other men the
population here has been encouraged by
health authorities to get vaccinated and
change their behavior to protect
themselves i think
definitely vaccination has worked and
also public health messaging around
around any any infectious disease is
very important but dr thomas says he's
already seen previously vaccinated
patients come in with infections will we
see more
case and the waste between the efficacy
of the vaccine is decreasing it should
be a two dose vaccine but with supplies
limited so far most people here are only
getting one meanwhile the who is looking
at recommending even smaller doses to
stretch thin reserves this strategy of
what's termed using fractional doses for
vaccines
is not a new strategy
all this as research out of halifax
finds more than half of canadians are at
least mildly concerned about monkey pox
dan specter global news montreal
just days before this year's final grand
slam tournament novak djokovic has
pulled out of the u.s open because he's
still unvaccinated against covet 19. the
serbian tennis superstar is still unable
to enter the united states due to the
country's kovid 19 travel restrictions
he announced his withdrawal on twitter
saying he will keep in good shape and
wait for an opportunity to compete again
djokovic has already been forced to exit
several major tournaments throughout
this year because of his refusal to get
vaccinated
a revealing memo sent to canada's top
soldier coming up what he was seemingly
warned about as the convoy protests in
ottawa raged on
new documents reveal top military
officials discussed what role the
canadian forces could play in helping
clear demonstrators in the so-called
freedom convoy from the nation's capital
through access to information laws
global news has learned senior defense
officials weighed the risks of getting
involved starting just moments after the
trudeau government's unprecedented
invocation of the emergencies act
mercedes stephenson reports
in the midst of the occupied streets the
honking
the parties
and the security threats the canadian
military was trying to figure out what
it could or should do if the government
came calling asking for help this being
a very unstandard situation something
very exceptional
there's no doubt that
they were anticipating being asked
documents obtained by global news show
the military's top lawyer sent legal
advice to the chief of the defense staff
general wayne ayer within minutes of the
government invoking the emergencies act
titled canadian armed forces assistance
to law enforcement legal basis and
authorities the document is heavily
redacted page after page blanked out but
the military was also drawing a blank
scrambling to figure out what to do here
he had an unprecedented situation in
that the emergencies act had never been
invoked it's not uncommon for the
military to help out in domestic
emergencies like forest fires floods
even the pandemic but using the military
to help law enforcement is a touchy
subject but sources tell global news
rcmp commissioner brenda lucky wanted
military help not in the form of
soldiers in the streets alongside police
but she did want access to the help of
heavy towing capabilities the military
had so just because you called in the
armed forces it doesn't mean you're
necessarily looking to have uniform
members in the streets
helping police to do law enforcement
both law enforcement and military
sources say neither the chief of the
defense staff or the minister of
national defense wanted troops anywhere
near law enforcement
the document appears to give legal
advice along the same lines warning the
canadian armed forces have quote
flexible authority but it does not apply
to the provision of the canadian armed
forces assistance in relation to law
enforcement matters the document
references the military acting in
relation to the definition of quote
threats to the security of canada but
redact what those threats if any may
have been ironically perhaps the only
clear thing here is the confusion with
the military saying the emergencies act
doesn't make it clear how or if the
military is empowered to do something
all of this certainly has been a wake-up
call that the canadian armed forces are
operating in a new and unprecedented
environment farah
thanks mercedes mercedes stevenson is
reporting from ottawa tonight
the u.s department of justice has now
submitted a redacted version of the
affidavit that led to the august 8th
search of former president donald
trump's home in florida and those
documents are set to be made public
tomorrow the affidavit convinced a
florida judge that there was probable
cause that evidence of a crime was
located at the estate during that search
fbi agents seized multiple boxes of
evidence including classified documents
taken from the white house when trump
left office the justice department had
opposed the unsealing of the affidavit
but the judge has ruled that it must
release the redacted version tomorrow
months after the tragic school shooting
that killed 19 children and two teachers
in uvalde texas the school district has
fired its police chief
in an emotional meeting wednesday
attended by victims families and
survivors the ivaldi school board
unanimously voted to terminate school
police chief pete arredondo's contract
he had been under intense criticism for
his command and hesitation during the
shooting which saw hundreds of officers
wait more than an hour before
confronting the shooter locked inside a
classroom he's the first police officer
to be fired over the incident
it's not over yet ahead why air travel
chaos is set to survive
past the summer
air travel this summer to say the very
least has been a whopping headache for
passengers so many have had holiday
plans upended by lengthy delays flight
cancellations and lost luggage so it's
no wonder canadians are wondering
whether the fall is going to be any
better well there's good news and
there's bad news and gaviola now on what
to expect when it comes to ticket prices
and potential disruptions ahead
passengers traveling through pearson
international canada's busiest airport
have had to pack a lot of patience
earlier this summer it was the worst
airport in the world for delays this
month it dropped to fifth we have been
non-stop throughout the whole summer
which has been
very demanding i must say um
especially with uh last minute travel a
lack of staff and so-called revenge
travel people desperate to hop on a
plane after staying put for most of the
pandemic all played a part
in transport canada's latest update 86
of flights left the country's top four
airports within an hour of their
scheduled departure time in early august
that is up from 75 percent the first
week of july still shy of the 92 percent
pre-pandemic it's marginal progress
demand typically drops in the fall as
people return to school and work
aviation analysts see an opportunity for
people looking for deals thanks to the
emergence of low-cost carriers like lynx
and flair airlines there's a lot more
competition for your travel dollars in
the fall than it would be in the summer
uh and that that competition translates
into lower fares so you'll see a
significant drop
in terms of pricing
on canadian routes but deals may not be
as easy to find for travel packages
abroad continuing the trend of higher
prices this summer tour operators are
dealing with inflated costs for just
about everything it's the combination of
hotels with
staffing they've had to put maybe wages
up of course airline tickets have gone
up as well
until airports and airlines improve
working conditions and adjust
compensation chronic staff shortages
will continue to be the new normal we're
going to be in those situations where
peak demand whether it's summer whether
it's christmas whether it's thanksgiving
whatever it is easter
you know you're all going to be
stressing the airports and the airlines
buckle up for more travel chaos on the
horizon ann gaviola global news toronto
stick around next indigenous pride faces
off with one of hollywood's most iconic
sci-fi monsters
by now either you or someone you know
has probably seen the sci-fi monster
movie pray the blockbuster has been the
number one streaming film in canada for
the past three weeks shot on alberta's
stoney nakota first nation the film is
the latest entry in the long-running
predator franchise but it's this film's
indigenous cast and the female lead
that's really turning heads as heather
urex west explains the movie's success
is showing how first nation meat tea and
inuit artists are ready to take
hollywood by storm
she may not look anything like arnold
schwarzenegger but the lead in the
latest predator franchise film commands
the screen as a bonafide action star a
warrior who is both female and
indigenous
it was really hard to even talk about
this without crying
michelle thrush is an indigenous actress
who stars alongside amber mid thunder in
prey i can remember my my oldest
daughter at one point when she was you
know a teenager a few years back but she
was like mom i wish i was white
and that broke my heart because we just
don't have the amount of
heroes that we need to inspire our youth
and for me
that was a hundred percent what my
motivation was in prey it's really
inspiring to see like more
representation because like growing up i
didn't really have a lot of that that
way he doesn't go all the way across but
laura royal has plenty of inspiration
now the film student is a week away from
graduation one of 20 indigenous students
at the counting coup film academy in six
sika first nation near calgary a program
co-founded by another indigenous actress
taking hollywood by storm at least get
you a pouch of juniper jessica matan
currently stars in the hit amc series
dark winds when i started out i didn't
get work for the first five years and
the the constant message in the room um
in the auditions rooms was jess you're a
great actor but the producers and
directors just don't know what to do
with your look i had to deal with a lot
of racism growing up in calgary but
that's changing now in a big way thanks
to a growing number of indigenous
writers directors and producers with
people like thrush and matin working to
inspire and mentor even more being
native you're part part of your duty if
you want to is to continue to help break
the cycles of intergenerational trauma
amongst our people the only reason i
ever got into this business was not for
for
glory and fame and money and red carpets
ever
it was always about using the art to
heal our people
by showing a generation of indigenous
youth that if a woman who looks like
them can slay the fiercest of predators
their dreams might just be possible too
heather urex west global news siksika
first nation alberta
the future looks bright that's global
national for this thursday night i'm
farah nasser and on behalf of our whole
team here on global national i want to
thank you so much for spending part of
your evening with us tonight's your
canada is overlooking grace lake at
narrow hills provincial park in smeaton
saskatchewan we love seeing your canada
so please keep emailing us those photos
to viewers at globalnational.com
until tomorrow take care of yourselves
and each other good night
[Music]